[Musik]
es trifft sich wirklich sehr gut das
anfang des jahres die filme das
japanischen anime studio skippy auf
netflix gestellt wurden und zwar nach
und nach alle und es gibt zwar einige
die mir für erwachsene geeignet sind
aber sehr sehr viele kann man
tatsächlich mit seinen kindern und das
zum beispiel der klassiker mein nachbar
zogen ein ganz wunderschöner film über
zwei schwestern mit dem vater aufs land
ziehen und dort gewesen und geistiges
waldes kennen lernen immer wieder gucken
kann ich zum beispiel auch heroes reise
ins zauberland das ist ein mädchen das
seine eltern auf einen ausflug abhanden
kommt und dort in ein badehaus für
götter und geister wie diesem gerät und
sich dort als hilfskraft verdingen muss
das klingt erstmal sehr fantastischen
seit ikarus ist tatsächlich ein film der
die alle gibt filme ein irgendwie
menschlich sehr nahe gehen weil sie so
warm und so schön erzählt sind und dabei
aber auch immer wieder skurril mit ganz
vielen kleinigkeiten im hintergrund
sodass man das auch als erwachsener
immer wieder gucken durch den tod des
asterix zeichner albert uderzo liegt es
natürlich nahe dass man sich jetzt in
die comics relativ doch auch die filme
können eine ganz gute ablenkung
verschaffen wenn man zu hause sitzt und
gerade die comic hefte nicht parat weil
die vielleicht noch bei den eltern im
schrank liegen oder so etwas worauf man
allerdings achten sollte ist dass man
nicht den fehler macht und sich die
filme mit den richtigen schauspielern
anschaut auch wenn dabei gérard
depardieu mitspielt sondern sich einfach
die zeichentrickfilme vornimmt
besonders asterix erobert rom das denn
nochmal der gesamt andere geschichte als
man sich aus den comics kennt wo es
tricks und obelix die herkules aufgaben
erfüllen müssen
und die sind auch in der deutschen
synchronisation erstaunlich lustig
wir hätten gerne den passierschein a38
und auch die anderen filme ob es jetzt
um kleopatra oder umgangen oder um die
briten geht die kann man sich an solchen
tagen wo man nicht vor die tür gehen
kann wirklich sehr gut anschauen
hände weg von mississippi ist
erste kinderfilm von detlev buck wir
haben gerade erst wieder geschaut mit
unserer tochter nichts macht der macht
richtig gute laune was er in dieser zeit
jetzt nicht so schlecht ist und zwar ist
er sowohl für erwachsene als auch für
kinder ein toller film ohne dass es
jetzt so eine parallelhandlung für die
erwachsenen braucht das ist eine
mischung aus detektivgeschichte western
so ein bisschen heile welt geschichte im
astrid lindgren stil
was ist allerdings nicht alleine für
sich ist auch wenn man das von der
handlung erst mal glauben möchte ist so
ein pferde mädchen filmen darum geht es
nicht vorrangig sondern dass es eher so
diese diese ganzen kleinen details in
dem dorf dieses spionieren wie meine
tochter gesagt hat das fand sie total
spannend und ja für uns erwachsene sind
die schauspieler einfach wahnsinn
katharina thalbach spielt die oma dolly
charly hübner ist dabei und christoph
maria herbst ist der bösewicht aber ganz
man man hat viel spaß man kann viel
lachen wer pferde mag ist da auch gut
aufgehoben aber wer detektivgeschichten
oder astrid lindgren filme mag ist in
diesem nostalgischen film von detlev
buck auch gut aufgehoben das ist die
märchen wahr das ist eine tschechische
serie für kinder und erwachsene
sie ist nämlich für beide gut für kinder
ist nämlich dass eine ganz tolle
geschichte über menschen aus dem
märchenreich die auf menschen aus den
menschen betreffen und dadurch weil die
alle ganz unterschiedlich wie eben kommt
es zu grossen verwicklung in beiden
räten und das ist für mich die schönste
serie
und wenn uns jetzt hier mal irgendwie zu
langweilig wird oder der lagerkoller
steht man die osterferien beginnen
wir uns das vielleicht nochmal vornehmen
das signalisiert dann noch mal angucken
gibt es auch auf youtube gibt also es
ist wirklich sehr
ich habe zwar selbst noch keine kinder
und bin auch kein kind mehr aber es gibt
wie ich finde viele viele kinder und
jugendfilme an denen auch erwachsene
spaß haben und alles steht kopf bis zu 1
finden so jetzt schön auf machen
irgendwas nach ist das gefährlich was
ist da denn den film der eher für etwas
ältere kinder so 18 vielleicht ist geht
es um die protagonistin release 11 und
deren eltern ziehen um und die finden
das ganz doof es geht aber vor allem
eigentlich darum was in dieser zeit in
ihrem kopf passiert und die eigentlichen
fünf protagonisten sind fünf emotionen
freude kummer ekel angst und wut und die
leighton eigentlich oder so zu sein weil
die durch den alltag
wie kommt ein flugzeug wir haben ein
flugzeug zieht man eines tages mischt
sich kümmert so sehr ein und freude und
kummer gehen im unterbewusstsein
verloren und sind dann ihren weg zurück
in die kommandozentrale finden und das
ist total fantasievoll erzählt geht so
um kindheitserinnerungen um den ersten
bei ausgedachten besten freund der
protagonistin ja es geht so ein bisschen
darum den kindern eben zu zeigen dass
man nicht immer nur fröhlich sein kann
und das ist auch okay es mal andere
sachen zu führen und das ist eine
wundervolle geschichte ich glaube dies
auch für erwachsene noch ein
riesengroßer spaß
ich empfehle star wars
star wars ist eine familiensaga in der
die familie skywalker über neuen teilen
weg begleitet wird
es geht um eine vater-sohn-beziehung es
geht aber auch um politik liebe und oben
die idee ritter natürlich die
faszination von star wars ist schon
jahrzehnte alt und wird auch die
nächsten jahrzehnte lang tragen und dann
muss ich mit der serie auseinandersetzen
weil schon grundschüler nach hause
kommen sagen ich will star wars gucken
und dann muss man sagen na ja einige
teile sind ab sechs jahren einige teile
sind ab 12 jahren das kann auch dauern
und man kann darüber diskutieren in
welcher reihenfolge man die filme guckt
denn ältere erwachsene haben der vier
begonnen 56 und so weiter und jetzt hat
man die möglichkeit chronologisch vor zu
gehen also von vorne 123 und so weiter
dann gibt es natürlich ein krassen
ästhetischen bruch zwischen teil drei
und vier
aber ich denke es am geschicktesten wenn
man mit eins anfängt weil sich dann die
geschichte sehr schön entwickelt groß
wird und und groß aufspannt manche dinge
lagerkoller ist hanni nanni mehr als
beste freunde die alte geschichte der
beiden zwillinge die nicht aufs internat
wollen und alles tun auch dort wieder
runter geworfen zu werden und am ende
dort bleiben
mit ganz tollen schauspielern 2017
verfehlen und maria stauber als
schulleiterin mit sascha vollmer von den
boss hoss als sehr entspannten vater und
jessica schwarz als gestresster mutter
für alle mitglieder der familie immer
wieder ein großes vergnügen
ich möchte euch die serie die regeln von
flor vorstellen dass die serie die lief
bis vor kurzem noch auf kika gibt es
aber immer noch in der mediathek und das
ist einfach eine serie die wir alle als
familie super lustig fanden
weil es eben um eine ganz normale
familie geht die in holland lebt und
florist die hauptdarstellerin dies zehn
jahre alt und hat einen großen bruder
und diese floor stellt eben bestimmte
regeln auf weil sie doch merkt in ihrer
familie geht einiges schief und deswegen
muss sie die regeln aufstellen weil die
familie sonst im chaos endet und
besonders lustig sind eben die eltern
weil die versuchen immer so alles
richtig zu machen besonders toll zu sein
und müssen dann aber merken dass sie in
ihrem toll sein dann doch regelmäßig
scheitern
also wir haben die serie wirklich super
gerne geguckt meine töchter sind acht
und 13 jahre alt ich fand dass beide
lustig mein mann und ich auch und das
schöne ist es sind sehr kurze filme also
das ist genau das richtige um nach einem
typischen chaotischen corona tag nochmal
richtig lachen zu können
[Musik]